PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture you've been talking
about implicitly defined
functions and implicit
differentiation.
So one of the reasons that
these are important is--
or that implicit
differentiation is important,
is that sometimes you have a
function to find implicitly
and you can't solve for it.
You don't have any
algebraic method
for computing the function
values as a formula, say.
So, for example, this function
that I've written on the board
that I've called w of
x is defined implicitly
by the equation that w of
x plus 1 quantity times
e to the w of x is
equal to x for all x.
So this function, some of
its values you can guess.
Like at x equals 0,
the function value
is going to be negative 1.
And the reason is that
this can't ever be 0,
so the only way to
get this side to be 0
is if w is negative
1 if this term is 0.
So some of its values
are easy to compute,
but some of its values aren't.
So for example, if I asked
you what w of 3/2 is,
it's very hard.
There's no algebraic way you can
manipulate this equation that
will let you figure that out.
So in that situation
you might still
care about what the
function value is.
So what can you do?
Well, you can try and find
a numerical approximation.
So in this problem I'd like you
to try and estimate the value
w of 3/2 by using a linear
approximation to the function,
to the curve-- yeah.
A linear approximation of
the function w of x in order
to compute this value.
So as a hint, I've given you--
so you're trying to
compute w of 3/2.
As a hint I'm pointing out
to you that w of 1 is 0.
Right?
If you put in x
equals 0 and w of 0
equals-- sorry-- if you put
in x equals 1 and w of 1
equals 0 on the
left hand side, you
do indeed get 1, as you should.
So, OK.
So, good.
So that'll give you a
hint about where you could
base your linear approximation.
So why don't you
pause the video,
take a few minutes to
work this out, come back,
and we can work it out together.
All right.
Welcome back.
So hopefully you've
had a chance to work
on this question a little bit.
So in order to do this linear
approximation that we want,
what we need to know are:
we need to know a base point
and we need to know the
derivative of the function
at that base point.
And those are the
two pieces of data
you need in order to construct
a linear approximation.
So we have a good
candidate for a base point
here, which is the point (1, 0).
So this curve,
whatever it looks like,
it passes through
the point (1, 0).
And that's the point we're going
to use for our approximation.
So we're going to use
the linear approximation
w of x is approximately equal
to w prime of 1 times x minus 1
plus w of 1 when x is
approximately equal to 1.
So this is the
linear approximation
we're going to use, and we
have that w of 1 here is 0.
So this is, this is equal to w
prime of one times x minus one.
Just, the w of 1 is 0.
It just goes away.
So in order to estimate w of
x, and in particular w of 3/2,
what we need to know is we need
to know the derivative of w.
OK?
And to get the derivative
of w, we need to use-- well,
we have only one piece
of information about w.
Which is we have
that it's defined
by this implicit equation.
So in order to get
the derivative of w
we have to use implicit
differentiation.
OK?
So let's do that.
So if we implicitly
differentiate this equation--
so let's start with
the-- the right-hand side
is going to be really easy.
Right?
We're going to differentiate
with respect to x.
The right-hand side
is going to be 1.
On the left-hand
side it's going to be
a little more complicated.
We have a product
and then this piece,
we're going to have a
chain rule situation.
Right?
We have e to the w of x.
So, OK.
So we're going to take
an implicit derivative
and on the left-- so OK,
so the product rule first.
We take the derivative
of the first part,
so that's just w prime of x
times the second part-- that's
e to the w of x-- plus
the first part-- that's
w of x plus 1-- times the
derivative of the second part.
So the second part
is e to the w of x.
So that gives me an e to the
w of x times w prime of x.
That's the chain rule.
So that's what happens
when I differentiate
the left-hand side.
And on the right-hand side I
take the derivative of x and I
get 1.
OK, good.
So now I've got
this equation and I
need to solve this
equation for w prime.
Because if you look up
here, that's what I want.
I want a particular
value of w prime.
And as always happens in
implicit differentiation,
from the point of
view of this w prime
it's only involved in the
equation in a very simple way.
So there's it multiplied by
functions of x and w of x,
but not-- you know, it's just
multiplied by something that
doesn't involve w prime at all.
And then here it's
multiplied by something that
doesn't involve w prime at all.
So you can just collect your
w prime's and divide through.
You know, it's just like
solving a linear equation.
So here, if we collect
our w prime's, this
is w prime of x times-- looks
like w of x plus 2 times e
to the w of x.
Did I get that right?
Looks good.
OK, so that's still equal to 1.
So that means that w
prime of x is just-- well,
just, you know-- it's equal
to 1 over w of x plus 2 times
e to the w of x.
OK, so this is true for every x.
But I don't need this
equation for every x.
I just need the particular
value of w prime at 1.
So that's, so I'm going to
take this equation, then,
and I'm just going
to put in x equals 1.
So I put in x equals 1--
well, let me do it over
here-- so I get w prime of 1.
And I just, everywhere I
had an x, I put in a 1.
So actually, in this equation
the only place x appears
is in the argument of w.
So this is w of 1 plus
2 times e to the w of 1.
OK.
So in order to get w prime of 1,
I need to know what w of 1 is.
But I had that.
I had it, it was
right back here.
There was the-- that
was my hint to you.
Right, this is why
we're using this point
as a base point, which
is we know the value of w
for this value of x.
So we take that value.
So w of 1 is 0.
So this is just 1 over--
well, 0 plus 2 is 2,
and e to the 0 is 1.
So it's just 1 over 2.
Sorry, that's written
a little oddly.
We can make it 2 times 1.
So 1 over 2.
OK.
So I take that back upstairs to
this equation that I had here.
And I have that w of x is
approximately equal to w
prime of 1 times x minus 1.
So w of x is approximately
equal to-- w prime of 1, we saw
is 1/2-- times x minus 1.
And that approximation was
good near our base point.
So that's good when x is near 1.
All right.
And then-- so this the
linear approximation.
And I asked for the linear
approximation, its value
at the particular
point x equals 3/2.
So w of 3/2 is approximately
1/2 times-- well, 3/2 minus 1
is also 1/2-- so
this is a quarter.
OK, so this is our
estimate for w of 3/2.
w of 3/2 is approximately 1/4.
If you wanted a
better estimate you
could try iterating
this process.
Now you might have a, you
know-- or choosing some base
point even closer if you could
figure out the value of w
and x near that, near this point
that you're interested in, 3/2.
So just to sum up what we did
was we had this implicitly
defined function w.
We wanted to estimate
its value at a point
where we couldn't
compute it explicitly.
So what we did was we did our
normal linear approximation
method.
Right?
So we wrote down our normal
linear approximation formula.
The only thing that
was slightly unusual
is that we had to use
implicit differentiation.
In order to compute
the derivative that
appears in the
linear approximation,
we implicitly differentiated.
OK?
So that happened just like
normal, and then at the end
we plugged in the values
that we were interested in,
to actually compute
the particular value
of that approximation.
So I'll end there.